what are you working yeah what hey guys
well it looks like you get to see me
open another loot crate
yup I'm here with away in Asia and I
still can't get away well as you can see
Luke ray are still shacking up with
crunchyroll looks like they're still in
the honeymoon phase though so they
aren't bored of each other and want to
cut each other throat off yet well
that's going to be a messy divorce
so as the theme this month is a
delicious or food themes in preparation
I've made my favorite Asian dish as you
can see here it's a ball of rice with
some Pocky sprinkled with some instant
ramen all right let's get this open all
right let's see what we got this time
alright so the first thing I see is yeah
this is exactly what I think it is and
it's just egg and bacon alright so you
see I've made an egg and bacon sandwich
haven't put any sauce in it because I
want to see how fresh the ingredients
taste so uh that's so let's give it a
shot all right so the sandwich was uh
okay it was ok you know it was fluffy
but didn't we have much potato no very
disappointed naturally I think it's just
cuz they added too many preservatives to
it so you know you might want to look
into that next time Luke right so for
the past few months people have been
asking me why I decided to move to my
family house in Thailand and you know
what I can't really put my finger in it
myself there's just something about this
place that makes me not miss my house in
England and next up we have a naruto
shippuden this looks like a ramen bowl
oh [ __ ] thanks Luke rate this is
actually really useful because you know
it's a little known fact that every
Asian needs to eat about three bowls of
ramen a day or or they've died of
malnutrition so here we are tan Asian
supermarkets so let me just show you
what it's like to shop as an Asian
all right that should just about do it
unfortunately though I don't know how
useful this will be for anyone who's not
Asian
haha look who it is it's professional
[ __ ] Amaru oh my god I actually had
she always wanted one of these
bubble wrap oh my god this reminds me of
my [ __ ] childhood man popping these
oh [ __ ] day holy [ __ ] that's full
tomorrow though you know I have given
her a lot of [ __ ] in the past so I think
I've actually got somewhere that she'll
actually truly enjoy good
there you go sitting where you truly
belong oh well I think we have some kind
of apron and uh no I actually I think I
know where this is from here is
definitely from shokugeki uh you know
that guy you know the one I mean so look
as much as they say they want this for
costume use only I assume they want us
to cosplay as this but I probably can't
put it to full use since I don't want to
get done for public indecency oh it's
not as no evening holy [ __ ] they got the
sweetness and lightening manga for those
of you who don't remember this was the
one that aired last season I think and
it was the one that had that really cute
little little girl on that now the thing
about anime and manga like Swedish and
lightning is that whenever I see you
I can't help but think that it's Japan's
government's way of telling otaku used
to just [ __ ] make babies already
because the thing is the children in
there are so cute that anyone reading or
washing it will automatically be
triggered with maternal instincts ah
[ __ ] ah [ __ ] and as usual we finish
things off with the ice cream phone tag
and of course the poster so here's the
shot of the poster and I have to say I'm
a very disappointed with the lack of
research you put into this Luke rate I
mean how can this girl be enjoying food
without having multiple orgasms do you
not know that every anime girl gets off
and eating anime food have we learned
nothing from shokugeki right now and
that was it
if you're interested in signing up for
next month's loot crate
it is blade themed so I assume you can
all the swords you want for all you edgy
dogs out there if you're interested you
can sign up at loot crate calm slash gig
up for ten percent off before November
the 27th oh and for anyone who wants to
cook Pocky rice instant noodle then I'll
definitely do a tutorial of this soon